moi je vais vous parler d'un produit
improbable
le genre de produit qui ne devrait pas
exister
le genre de produit que si vous allez
chez un investisseur ou un pompier
pour partenaire et vous traite de fou
donc
imaginez vous juste souvent d'être dans
une très vieille ferme en suisse nous
sommes entre
zurich et st-gall
près au milieu on s'appelle tokyo boucle
nous sommes à mille mètres d'altitude
une femme qui a été vite pendant
75 ans 81 ans et que deux enfants qui
qui joue temps en temps dans
ces endroits où il ya environ
40 personnes qui vit le village à côté
le postier ils ouvrent
ils oublient l'office
quand il se sent bien
si la base est il ouvre pas qui a pas de
courrier
imaginez un endroit pareil
est là on va faire du saumon fumé
donc
eh oui
il s'appelait artscape cubel
grands acteurs théâtralement
vivons à zurich a dit si tu es un jour
j'ai besoin d'acheter
une ferme
ailleurs et faire des foins sais pas si
vous imaginez des foins puis à main pour
le vendre au zoo de zurich
il a aussi il a aussi pris des chiens je
crois japonais qu'il a croisés avec des
chiens allemand
je sais pas ce qu'il sait que brasser
sais pas comment ça s'appelait mais
c'était aussi invité pour lui de vendre
des produits comme ça et
juste avant de commencer il arrivé à
berlin il en train de faire un tour mais
je crois que c'était marquis de sade
il rencontre un monsieur qui s'appelle
kaeppelin qui lui dit moi je vais vous
faire des fours pour fumer du saumon en
fait pour filmer des poissons
et qui maintient je vais acheter cette
ferme
une
toque et vous qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
le faire là bas
view mais pourquoi pas sauf ce qu'il a
oublié de lui dire c'est que quand il
construit des fours ses défauts pour 200
poissons
papou un ou deux
et donc ce monsieur sait trouver
maintenant avec des fours six mois plus
tard dans laquelle pour avoir un poisson
pour lui il fallait qu'ils produisent
pas génial
il a perdu passablement d'argent et
est à ce moment là il revient vers le
choc a plané duquel j'ai écouté j'ai
perdre l'argent je peux pas produire 200
saumon pour en avoir un pour moi
donc il faut que j'arrête
mais qu'après lui a dit mais
web a dit que vous voulez gagner de
largent
dans lavie russie
empêcher les esturgeons dans la mer
caspienne
et renforcer le dos et l'esp urgent
et ça on va appeler sa belle équipe et à
elle y à
fait sain et fait cela avec du saumon
vous allez voir
alors que bonn il a fait ça avec du
saumon il a eu un succès extraordinaire
mais finalement
c'était pas vraiment son truc
c'est un grand fou dit c'est un groupe
d'astronomes mais c'était pas quelqu'un
qui voulait gérer une entreprise et la
voix j'arrive
j'ai 26 ans
et je les rencontre monsieur tube le
gérant consent partenaires monsieur
cloutier
je trouve l'idée pas mal vient du saumon
dans le camp des alpes suisses
donc j'appelle mes parents d'élise une
idée
vous permet d'y
signer à copenhague
iliad les verts autour
là il ya du poisson
normalement le sort de la mer et on le
fume
et toi tu as eu l'idée brillant des
messins dans les alpes et smith
puis à ce moment-là il regarde ma mère
et on voit très bien c'est très clair et
c'est son fils à elle
la même année j'avais fait votre
connerie
parce que
ma grande passion dans la vie en dehors
de la bouffe c'est la musique
et en 84 85 il y a le premier système
logiciel qui vient société appelle atari
ou peu joué
un peu de un peu en bijoux et notes ou
des mélodies et puis ça a pris dans les
partitions
aujourd'hui c'est très très courant mais
en 84 85 c'était tout sauf courant
c'était une véritable révolution surtout
pour quelqu'un comme moi qui ne savent
pas lire la musique
donc je me suis dit
puisqu'il devait faire du saumon dans
les alpes et suisse pour s'y faire un
concert symphonique
étant j'ai écrit à cette folie
simplement je ne sais pas lire donc je
suis pas sur les mêmes 7.6 vous imaginez
vous écrivez un livre mais vous
n'arrivez pas à lire si ce livre est
correct ou pas correct
donc
à peu fait un peu tâche
et je me suis dit alors comment est ce
que je peux
voici ce que j'ai fait est juste
il faut alors qu'istres
à genève il n'y a pas beaucoup de
regrets je regarde un look est suisse
romande
donc j'appelle quelqu'un qui appelle
quelqu'un qui appelle quelqu'un puis
finalement j'ai réussi à louer leurs
esquisses remontent pour un jour
pour jouer ben se polit
sauf
n'avait pas compris l'importance d'un
chef d'orchestre
non j'arrive ce jour là
il ya soixante cinq musiciens en salle 1
sermersheim
et il me demande qui sait qu'ils veulent
nous diriger
moi
très bien votre bâton
j'en ai pas mais peut-être on va prendre
une fourchette dans le continent et puis
ça va très bien avec moi j'aime la
bouffe
donc ce que j'avais ce que je savais pas
puisque ce logiciel avait pris les
parties sont que j'avais
et j'avais écrit tout ce que j'avais
joué
et il l'a fait à sa sauce
donc le parti pour le violent il est à
lire sur les flûtes le parti de flûte
italie seuls trois bandes métropole est
allé partout et donc est finalement et
puis vous savez quand on écrit pour un
orchestre il faut savoir comment le
violent joue
il faut savoir que l'on respire
moi j'avais aucun de ça
donc
je suis là avec mes fourchette
il ya personne dans la salle sauf ma
mère puisque j'ai invité ma mère en
disant c'est ma première symphonique
vous quand même qu'il y avait bien
longtemps
le son le ce difficile à vous exprimer
le kata phonique est arrivé
en tout cas c'était ai jamais entendu
quelque chose aussi horrible de ma vie
mais vraiment
le le premier violon de l'orchestré 20
vers moi et me dit monsieur
ses oeuvres c'est pourquoi faire
un film publicité
et j'étais tellement choqué parce qu'à
folie cet horrible son et tout ce qu'ils
aiment et puis à prendre ma propre
audace
je vais écouter c'est pour mon répondeur
téléphonique à la maison
cinq ans après je reviens avec le saumon
mais cinq ans après j'ai un déjeuner
avec le responsable du tourisme à genève
et claude nobs le fondateur du montreux
jazz
et on parle des gens bizarres
et qui à genève ya beaucoup de gens
bizarres
et puis il ya claude michon qui dit oui
vous savez il ya même un mec qui a loué
le hockey suisse romande pour son
répondeur téléphonique
et moi non
mais
ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que quand on décide de faire du
saumon fumé dans les alpes suisses
ça devient une véritable une véritable
comment dire oeuvre des vies
en rêve on s'imagine
il faut beaucoup de persévérance peut y
arriver
et je la change
dix ans après d'enregistrer avec
le london symphony orchestra londres il
vous promet ça s'est très très bien
passé
et puis j'ai eu beaucoup de chance de
voir cette aventure avec de saumon fumé
promis chemin énorme
alors la suisse c'est pas un pays où le
poisson suisse surtout
la suisse alémanique profonde c'est un
pays de viande
et d au moins on a réussi à créer
quelque chose de très particulier
a envoyé ses séides elixer plus cette
vieille ferme
ces ruines que sanitaire avant
aujourd'hui non seulement en produits du
saumon fumé mais on a aussi le studio
d'enregistrement
et j'aimais les deux choses ensemble
et j'appelle ça ma maison
d'irresponsabilité
mais ces deux en fait c'est mes deux
passions j'ai arrivait à m la bouffe et
la musique dans la même maison
alors il n'y a pas vraiment un laissons
à prendre ici c'est pas parce que j'ai
un des sons à vous donner j'ai pas non
plus ne s'est pas décidé qui nous donne
s'il vous plaît n'allait pas fumer tue
souvent dans les alpages friis donc je
sais qu'on est là pour donner des idées
puis les faire circuler c'est pas ça du
tout ce que je peux en tirer quelque
chose c'est de dire
même quand ça a l'air improbable qu'en
salle est impossible
pour le faire quand même
ce qui étend en temps ça marche
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]